[Música]
Hasta cuánto puedes contar con los dedos
parece una pregunta como una respuesta
obvia después de todo la mayoría tenemos
10 dedos o para ser más precisos ocho
dedos y dos pulgares esto Da un total de
10 dígitos en las dos manos que usamos
para contar hasta 10 no es casualidad
que los 10 símbolos que usamos en el
sistema de numeración moderno se llaman
dígitos pero esa no es la única manera
de contar en algunos lugares es
costumbre contar hasta 12 con una sola
mano Cómo bueno cada dedo se divide en
tres secciones Y tenemos un indicador
natural para indicar cada una El pulgar
eso nos da una forma fácil de contar
hasta 12 con una mano
Y si queremos contar más alto podemos
usar los dígitos de la otra mano para
contar la cantidad de Voces hasta cinco
grupos de 12 o 60
mejora aún usemos las secciones de la
segunda mano para contar 12 grupos de 12
hasta 144
[Música]
eso es una gran mejora Pero podemos
contar más alto encontrando más partes
contables en cada mano por ejemplo cada
dedo tiene tres secciones y tres
pliegues un total de seis cosas
contables ahora podemos contar hasta 24
en cada mano y usar la otra mano para
marcar grupos de 24 y eso nos da 576
podemos contar más alto parece que hemos
alcanzado el límite de partes diferentes
de los dedos que podemos contar con
precisión Así que pensemos algo
diferente
una de nuestras mejores invenciones
matemáticas es el sistema de notación
posicional donde la colocación de
símbolos permite diferentes magnitudes
de valor como en el número 999 Aunque Se
use el mismo símbolo tres veces cada
posición indica un orden de magnitud
así podemos usar el valor de posición en
los dedos para batir el récord anterior
olvidémonos de las secciones de los
dedos ahora y veamos el caso más simple
de tener Solo dos opciones por dedo
arriba y abajo esto no nos permitirá
representar potencias de 10 pero es
perfecto para el sistema de conteo que
usa potencias de dos También conocido
como binario en binario cada posición
duplica el valor de la anterior Así que
podemos asignar a los dedos valores de
uno dos cuatro ocho y así hasta 512 y
cualquier número entero positivo Hasta
cierto límite puede expresarse como suma
de estos números por ejemplo el número 7
es 4 + 2 + 1 y lo podemos representar
levantando estos tres dedos
Mientras tanto 250 es 128 + 64 + 32 + 16
+ 8 + 2 qué Alto podemos llegar ahora
ese sería el número con los 10 dedos
levantados 1023
es posible contar más alto depende de su
destreza si puede doblar los dedos hasta
la mitad eso nos permite tres estados
diferentes bajo medio levantado Pero
puede contar usando un sistema
posicional de base 3 hasta 59 mil 48
[Música]
Y si puede doblar los dedos en cuatro
partes diferentes o más puede contar más
alto incluso es el límite depende de
usted y de su propia flexibilidad e
Ingenio
incluso con los dedos en Solo dos
posibles estados ya estamos trabajando
de manera bastante eficiente de hecho a
las computadoras están basadas en el
mismo principio cada microchip consta de
diminutos interruptores eléctricos que
pueden encender o Apagar es decir que la
base 2 es su forma predeterminada de
representar números y así como podemos
usar este sistema para contar más de mil
solo con los dedos una computadora puede
realizar miles de millones de
operaciones con solo contar unos y ceros
para saber más de las Matemáticas
alucinantes aprenda sobre el crecimiento
exponencial con nuestra lección sobre
Cómo doblar un papel para llegar a la
luna y no olvides suscribirse a nuestro
canal
[Música]